[Musique]
des frigos des montagnes de frigo
abandonnés 300000 c'est le nombre
d'appareils réfrigérants au Québec qui
serait inadéquatement recyclé chaque
année produisant au temps de gaz à effet
de serre que 100000 voitures les
recycler correctement c'est possible et
surtout essentiel c'est très important
parce que l'appareil va toucher à
plusieurs domaines environnemental donc
on peut penser évidemment au gaz qui
détruit à gauche de zone qui créent
aussi des gaz à effet de serre mais dans
les réfrigérateurs il y a aussi
plusieurs
matières recyclables purfera se
spécialise dans le recyclage d'appareils
réfrigérant chaque objet qui passe le
pas de la porte et désosser en moins de
deux heures on va broyer l'appareil en
morceaux d'environ 3 4 cm et là le
plastique les métaux vont aller d'un
côté et toute la mousse de polyuréthane
va aller d'un autre côté
les différents plastiques sont triés
idem pour les métaux les pièces
électroniques sont mises de côté tout
comme le vert et les autres matériels la
mousse de polyuréthane et pulvérisée en
une fine poudre on se retrouve ici c'est
la poudre de polyuréthane qui vient de
l'isolation du réfrigérateur par
laquelle on a commencé toutes les
petites bulles qui contenaient le gaz à
l'eau carbure qu'on a récupéré dans les
autres étapes la farine peut être entre
autre utilisée dans le ciment dans la
sfalte ou comme absorbant industriel le
gaz lui ne sert pour la couche d'ozone
est liquéfier et ensuite détruit pour le
reste tout serait transformé revalorisé
ou recycler on est très fier de pouvoir
faire un travail à la hauteur de 97% de
récupération de matière quand un
appareil passe le pas de la porte ici
chez puret c'est l'action la plus simple
individuellement pour lutter contre les
changements climatiques c'est de
s'occuper de ces appareils
réfrigérateurs c'est reconnu dans le
monde
je le choisis la pointe et le directeur
général de l'organisme abus non lucratif
ou recycle le seul partenaire reconnu
par Recy Québec pour un recyclage
conforme des appareils réfrigérants
de rue nous on a eu beaucoup d'études
aussi qu'on a regardé au niveau du
comportement des Québécois et c'est ça
fait partie de la compréhension des gens
que ces appareils là seront bien risqués
or sur la centaine de ferrailleurs au
Québec un seul se conforme au règlement
et collabore avec gros recycle on
demande que ça soit contrôlé le plus
rapidement possible on s'attend à ce que
la réglementation soit appliquée le
gouvernement s'engage à faire plus
d'inspection en attendant pour s'assurer
que vos appareils soient bien pris en
charge le mieux est de les déposer dans
un écocentre ou de les confier à un
détaillant lorsque vous en achetez un
œuf un service gratuit ici Elisa Serey
Radio-Canada Montréal